the jurgen experience when you're
training athletes
for jiu jitsu and one of the interesting
things about the gordon
ryan conversation that i had recently i
didn't know that you are
gary tonan's striking coach as well oh
yeah
pretty amazing that you can do both that
you can
train them in both jiu jitsu and also
train them in striking and i know you
have a background in striking but still
when you're training an athlete like
gary
um if you're training someone like
gordon for
jiu jitsu i'm sure there's some emphasis
on takedowns
but it's not a primary concern the
primary concern is submissions right
like
oftentimes you'll see gordon will sit
and
pull guard the all these things that are
not
possible in mma or very rare
what how much of a shift is it to train
them
for mixed martial arts because you're
clearly training him to strike and
training himself but
ultimately this the skill set the
best part of their skill set involves in
submission that's correct
um the big challenge
for most jiu-jitsu players when they try
to apply their their craft and mix
martial arts
is one can they get it to the ground
that's a challenge in itself and an even
greater challenge is
can you keep it on the ground okay it
means nothing if you take someone down
if they just spring back up within three
to five seconds it's
it's energy spent that had no reward
um a sad thing about jiu-jitsu
is that when it's practiced there's
almost always a kind of gentleman's
agreement
that there's going to be a top player
and a bottom player
and if you start in the bottom you stay
in the bottom
the moment you get into a mixed martial
arts context that goes right out the
window
and now you have two responsibilities
you don't just have to
pass your opponent's guard from top
position you have to hold them down
while you're doing it
and that's that's not easy um
when you look at the notion of escape in
jiu jitsu
the overwhelming majority of escapes in
the sport of judah 2 are escapes to god
position
if you're mounted you elbow escape you
put them back in god
if the guy's got side pin on you your
elbow escape put them back in god
if the guy's behind you you do a forward
roll spin back into them put them back
in god
90 of the escapes in jiu-jitsu are
escaped back to god position
and so when you start in bottom position
you tend to stay in bottom position
now contrast that with the sport of
wrestling where the overwhelming
majority of escapes are escapes to
standing back up to a neutral position
on your feet
that means that when jujitsu players
face
other forms of grappling they're not
trying to put us back in guard
they're trying to stand up and jiu-jitsu
players never practice against that
when they're doing their daily training
and so suddenly you've got a guy who
just assumes for his entire career that
if he's on top the other guy's going to
play guard
and this guy's not playing god at all
he's just pushing your head standing up
and hit passing up to his feet
the jiu-jitsu guy's like well i had to
opposition why aren't you playing god
and so they're now put into an area
where
nothing in their training has really
prepared them for this
and jujitsu is going to have to mature
i've always said juditsu's one of the
greatest products i ever saw in my life
i wouldn't have invested 30 years of my
life introduced if i didn't believe that
with all my heart and all my soul
but like any great product it has its
deficiencies
jujitsu always had three major
deficiencies
leg logs takedowns
and thirdly the one that no one talks
about the ability to impose
top position once it's gained
a huge part of my career has been
the recognition and the attempt to
change
these three great faults in jujitsu
as much as i love jiu-jitsu we've got to
take a step back and take an honest look
at it it's got these three
deeply entwined faults within it
leglocks was the most obvious one in a
game
which was supposedly all about control
leading to submission there was an
arbitrary rule that 50 percent of the
body couldn't be attacked that was
lunacy
and over the last 10 years i believe
it's fair to say we've reached a point
where that is no longer the case that
that is
a great weakness within judith so the
younger generation of jiu-jitsu
i would match them against any grappling
art in the world on leg locks with
no fear whatsoever that i couldn't have
said that 15 years ago
but things have changed now we need to
address the other two great weaknesses
jiu jitsu has to do something about the
crisis which is starting to emerge
around takedowns and the ability to
impose top position
what you've seen among jiu-jitsu
athletes now who go into mixed martial
arts is they just have to turn to other
arts they have to learn wrestling they
have to
learn these and there's nothing wrong
with that but the truth is that jujitsu
has become
a relative a smaller and smaller
component of mixed martial arts
rather than what it was when it first
started which is a dominant force in
mixed martial arts
now for most of the athletes youtube is
something you learn to stay out of some
pesky submission holds
it's not the be-all and focus for most
of the athletes in mixed martial arts
most of them are centered around
kickboxing skills and wrestling
i think that we have done a great job of
overcoming
one out of three great problems in
jiu-jitsu
but there's still two more to go catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify watch back
catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience